kashmir deer roamed the snowy slopes of
the datigam national park on the
outskirts of srinagar in search of food
there are only 260 of the animals left
in the world locally known as hangul the
male stags are characterized by their
impressive antlers hangul travel to
lower ground in search of food in the
winter given their low numbers
conservationists say they aren't taking
any chances
wildlife workers scatter vegetables for
the animals although there are some
uninvited guests at the feast these are
the
spots basically which are being visited
by the animal on the regular basis so
then
actually these spots are being already
identified in advance and every time
there's a heavy snow fall the field
stops just go and ensure that at the
right places this supplementary feed is
being scattered on the ground
there were up to 5 000 hangul in indian
administered kashmir in the 1990s but
that number had fallen to less than 200
by 2015.
in the old days the hanguls used to roam
in the area in orchards everywhere but
over the years i've witnessed a sharp
decline in their numbers maybe because
of poaching or other reasons now we
hardly see anything
conservationists blame poaching and
habitat loss for the decline teams of
wildlife volunteers patrol for poachers
when the hangul come down from the
mountains because this is the real time
during which we can maybe during which
the poaching there's a chance of
poaching in the in and around the
dachigam national park so our team uh we
petrol uh around the dachigam national
park in these conservation areas in
these tough times
but experts say the bigger challenge now
is the loss of habitat
the landscape has changed industries
have come up people are living near the
border of the park
they're also losing grazing grounds as
nomadic herds migrate here for pastures
for their cattle
while the small increase in hangul
numbers over the past seven years is
being celebrated conservationists say
the real measure of success will be if
they can once again survive in the wild
and without help
elizabeth puranam al jazeera